do you think what what Barkley and Cha
said last week like do you view that as
a legitimate
critique and what exactly did they say I
mean essentially it was um like we those
both those guys said we struggled with
some conditioning stuff early in our
career and like that got better and we
kind of we see that in this game a
little bit
too uh if it comes from a great place
and a place where they just want to see
me do better thank you but if if it
comes from anywhere else everybody
entitled their own opinion can't control
that is there any of that stuff that you
hear and you feel like is too far or or
they do too much or stuff like that um
at the end of the day I can't control
what no grown man do can't control what
no grown adult does all I can do is uh
control the things I can't control lock
in on myself lock in on my teammates
coaches and everybody with the Pelicans
the city and try to win